- When you're thinking about trying
to pluck your eyebrows super thin, don't.
'Cause like, we looked
gnarly during that time.
(perky music)
- Hi, come on in.
- [Man in Black Hat] How's it going?
- [Woman interviewing]
Good, how are you doing?
- Good.
- Awesome, you hit your mark perfectly.
So I want you to close your eyes.
We're gonna go back in time.
Once you feel like you're ready,
I want you to open your eyes,
say whatever comes to your mind first.
- [Voiceover] Do you wanna
talk to your younger self?
- Should I?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- All right.
Let's do it.
(laughs)
- How are you brave little--
- I'm sorry.
- I'm sorry that you feel
so alone and isolated.
- I know you're scared right now
because you don't know
exactly what's going on.
- People around you, they just
don't understand right now.
- We want to play with these toys,
they want you to play with the other toys.
- They don't see you right
now the way you see yourself.
- You didn't have anything to worry about.
- You're not crazy, you
are who you say you are.
You are one of the boys.
- I remember every night you would wish
that one day you'd grow up
to be this beautiful woman.
- You really are as
beautiful as you thought
that you might be, or
that some people told you.
- You are going to be wonder
woman when you grow up.
- You're gonna be okay.
The future is bumpy and you think things
are going slow now.
- The world becomes a much
easier place for people like you.
- There will be doctors who will help you
and understand you and other people
that feel just like you do
and you'll be part of it.
'Cause you're still gonna be here.
- You will live in a bigger city,
find other people that you relate to.
- They're gonna love you so much.
They're gonna give you so much support.
- You have to be patient
because the future
is where you can be free.
You just gotta keep going.
- When you see that first Whoopi Goldberg
special on HBO, think to
yourself you can do that.
You can get paid to make people laugh.
- Your life is no less
worthy than anyone else's.
Because you're trans,
you are extra special.
- The world is so big
and there are so many
people who are going
through the exact same thing
as you because there's a future
that waits for you that's
far less small and scary
than your junior high or
your high school experience.
- I don't want to give
away too much to you.
You're gonna have an awesome life
but always, always try to love your body
and always try to love yourself because
that's the most important thing.
And I love you.
- I love you.
Bye, cutie.
Going back to the future,
see you there, bye.